uh chris sunday surprise draft they say
i'm asking you the question i'm waiting
for the question to be revealed here it
is
russell wilson became the second
quarterback to throw five touchdown
passes against bill belichick's patriots
who was the other oh wow
five touchdown passes against bill
belichick's patriots
i have no clue it's going to be somebody
obscure but uh i i'll pay no no it's not
peyton manning not obscure at all nope
nope not obscure but not peyton manning
drew brees 2009. oh 2009.
monday night football game right
remember that that was uh yep i can
still remember belichick on the
sidelines with brady
saying he can't get this team to play
the way he wants it to and that little
first glimpse into belichick behind the
scenes
the the sunday surprise draft is a
little more difficult this week because
most of the favorites won so there
wasn't really even though the games were
exciting there wasn't something that
wasn't all that unexpected but i have to
go with the jacksonville jaguars oh they
took the tennessee titans all the way
down to the wire and arguably
could have won there was a apparently a
badly mischieving clowning offside call
i haven't seen that yet that's something
i'm going to look into after the after
the the program that would have helped
the jaguars but you know it took a long
field goal from stephen guskowski who
missed all those kicks on monday night
to ultimately beat the jaguars but they
fall behind and they don't fold the
tents they keep coming down 10 down 14.
we don't care we keep going and this
team is too young to know that they
should be freaked out in those moments
and uh you know for all the criticism
and all the suggestion they're tanking
even though they've lost they're
one-on-one
they beat the colts and that went over
the colts looks a hell of a lot better
after what the colts did to the vikings
yesterday chris yeah no it it definitely
does and i think just even the way
jacksonville played all together you're
right it makes me even think
differently about their week one win
you're right just all i look at and go
oh wait wait jacksonville is better than
maybe we gave him credit for it and even
though i think they were outplayed in
that week one game again they show that
they're
they're they're able to stay competitive
against anybody and gardner minshew you
know great job by him i mean had two two
interception that kind of got him off on
a bad start early and then had a ball
where it got tipped to the line of
scrimmage where he threw very low uh and
i think jeffrey simmons got a hand on it
knocked it in the air but certainly that
was one of the surprises because i
thought tennessee had that game in
control too at one point i'm gonna go
with leonard fournette somebody we just
saw in that match up i mean leonard
fournette i don't know what to expect
with him you know why did he get cut
from jacksonville how did that happen
he's a guy that i've always believed in
you know that i mean i see his talent
but i started to wonder just after last
week and okay they didn't get anything
going man maybe he's there's something
to him maybe he's not where he needs to
be but yesterday i think he'd probably
establish himself as the new go-to
running back for that tampa bay team i
mean he's just a freak of nature again
you see the physicality in which he runs
and then he can be a guy that can put a
game away and it's not only surprising
just to see him but needed to see tampa
be able to run the ball effectively
anyways i think that's something we need
to see we know how good brady is off of
play action and all those type of things
and they stink at play action right now
so they're going to need that run game
to help that out but fournette was a
pleasant surprise yesterday
yeah i i look
it's going to take time for him to get
to where he ultimately can be they
didn't use him all that much in the
first week he had one nice run but then
he had some some losses and it was just
like it was the saints it was the saints
it was the toughest game of the year
right and fournette can only make that
offense better as the season goes
i i you know this one
i got to explain it the right way
because it's going to look strange the
ravens beating the texans the way they
did kind of surprised me because
when you watch back the week one ravens
browns game i had some concerns about
whether or not the ravens really were
as good as we thought as you know the
38-6 win and we know how close it was
and it could have gone either way
for them to go to houston and the texans
defending playoff team had extra time to
get ready for baltimore to be as
dominant as they are and that's kind of
gotten lost in the shuffle by everything
else that went on yesterday i i am
surprised that this team
has had
no ill effects
from going 14-2 last year and getting
punched in the mouth in the playoffs
they seem to be exactly
where they were last year and they seem
to be ready to start ripping through one
after another and it will be interesting
to see whether they can avenge
only
uh what was their second loss last year
they've won 14 in a row now they had two
regular season losses last year the
chiefs were one the browns were the
other they get a shot at the chiefs next
monday night yeah that'll be fun to
watch i really will that baltimore in
your face defense against you know
patrick mahomes and that speed at
receiver um
but baltimore the thing that jumps out
to me to to what you're saying here too
is just that when they have their their
foot on your throat they they step down
they don't like let you like hey do you
do you need to breathe a little bit more
before we do it or like you you want one
more chance
then they close it out and that's what
you saw the last two weeks and you know
week one they closed it out with passing
and lamar jackson being awesome that
week you know then yesterday it's
it's just unbelievable run attack and
who do you stop all right here's my
sunday surprise um analytics i'm sick of
them okay and this is why
all right because you brought me to this
game i wasn't gonna do this for the
draft but this game and then of course
you're too young you're too young to be
telling the analytics guys to get off
your lawn yeah well get off you are 40.
get off my lawn then fine but either way
okay
uh
analytics
you know mike mccarthy going for two
down by nine i don't know if that's
analytics or not if that's just
stupidity all right but that was stupid
i don't know any other way to say it
down by nine go for two no you kick the
extra point and make it a one score game
i mean if they don't cover the onside
kick we are talking about mike mccarthy
for one of the two of the dumbest
decisions we've seen in two weeks really
okay so then there's that also earlier
in that game dan quinn 26-7 i didn't
know like nfl coaches became oracles and
they could tell the future of games and
how many points will be needed exactly
45 minutes down the road or an hour and
45 minutes he had an inkling yeah he had
an inkling he was going to need that
point no he went for he lost that point
he was wrong
yes i know but he had he had he was
going for the two
because he had a feeling that he wasn't
going to hold his lead well he lost that
one that was the game still tied so you
know whoopty do and then i gotta go to
bill o'brien okay
i mean again analytics they're down
three nothing they're on their own 34
yard line it's fourth and one i'm sure
analytics said if you go for it you have
a 90 chance of winning the game but do
the analytics break down that the
baltimore ravens have the biggest
baddest mofos on the planet on the other
side of the ball and a defensive coach
that'll do crap they does it how do they
come up with that formula so that made
no sense and that was the end of that
game that was it was over right there
three nothing you give baltimore here
here in baltimore here's a few plays to
score touchdown and just end it for us
and that was it i just don't get it i'm
so sick of that
here's how i can explain it as quickly
as possible because we still have one
more round to go and we have limited we
got 90 seconds we got 90 seconds so
we'll explode
let's let's put a pin in that until
airing of grievances okay next one for
me i was surprised to see so many
coaches defying the mandate from the
league office to wear your damn mask
over your mouth and your nose frank like
your nose doesn't get an example it's
not gonna be an issue as joe torrey
tweeted yesterday if it fits over his
nose it fits over anyone's nose there's
gonna be some punishments handed out
today and i'm surprised so many coaches
didn't comply yeah you're you're
probably right it's a tough one i know
coaches are they're having a hard time
communicating into those microphones and
it's become an issue but it's not a good
look you're right and they're going to
lose some cash today all right my other
sunday surprise is um
not touching the runner on the first
play of the game and letting him run for
80 touch 80 yard touchdown i mean what
raheem mostert toss right jets they
don't even touch him
not a hand nothing flag football
two-hand touch touchdown doesn't matter
that's like shocking in the nfl to see
that didn't matt breed it didn't matter
to do the same thing last year against
the browns on monday night football
second game of the year exactly right
right i mean in mozart last week it was
like the second drive of the game he
caught the 75 yard touchdown pass nobody
touched them i just you it's very rare
you see that in football that was
amazing way to start the game amazingly
bad for matt casey's jets
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports